ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, our lecture
today is about curve plotting.
And actually, I call it 'Curve
Plotting with and without
Calculus' to emphasize the
fact that what we're
interested in is curve plotting
and that calculus, in
particular, differentiation,
gives us a powerful tool that
is not available to us, at least
in an accessible form
without the calculus.
Let's see what I mean by this
by going back to a typical
high school type analytical
geometry problem.
For example, sketch the curve
'y' equals 'x squared'.
Now we all know that the graph
of 'y' equals 'x squared' is
something like this.
And how'd we find that?
You may recall that in the truer
sense of the word, the
pre-calculus approach really is
curve plotting as opposed
to curve sketching.
And I hope I make that
a little bit
clearer as we go along.
Namely, you look to see for
certain values of 'x' what
value of 'y' corresponds
to that.
And then we locate the
corresponding point 'x' comma
'y' in the plane of
the blackboard.
And what we then do is somehow
or other, take a French curve,
or whatever it happens to be,
and we sketch a smooth curve
through the given points.
This is the usual technique.
The question that comes up is,
that as long as there are
spaces between the points that
you've sketched, how can you
be sure that the curve that
you've drawn isn't inaccurate?
In other words, starting in
reverse here, let's suppose
that these are the points I've
happened to sketch for the
curve 'y' equals 'x squared'.
And by the way, as is often the
case in our course, don't
be misled that we pick something
as simple as 'y'
equals 'x squared'.
I simply, again, wanted to
pick something that was
straightforward enough so that
we could concentrate our
attention on what the
mathematical implications were
rather than to be bogged
down by computation.
But the idea is this.
Going back to the problem 'y'
equals 'x squared', suppose we
had located these points and
now we said, let's sketch a
smooth curve through these.
What would have been wrong
with say, doing
something like this?
Why, for example, couldn't
this have been the curve?
Now again, notice that in
terms of mathematical
analysis, not necessarily
calculus but in terms of
mathematical analysis, we could
immediately strike out
something like this.
For example, notice in terms
of our input versus output,
this says that for any real
input since the square of a
real number cannot be negative,
the output can never
be negative.
And pictorially, this means that
no portion of our diagram
can be below the x-axis.
In other words, without
knowing anything about
calculus but knowing a little
bit about arithmetic, we can
supplement our knowledge
of how the points go by
saying look-it .
Something like this can't happen
because in this region
over here 'y' would
be negative.
And we know from the
relationship that 'y' equals
'x squared' that 'y'
cannot be negative.
Well you see, armed with this
information, we could say, OK,
given the same points here,
why couldn't the curve go
through something like this?
That's what the question
mark is in here for.
Obviously, this is
not the graph of
'y' equals 'x squared'.
But the question is, noticing
that this curve doesn't go
below the x-axis, what's
wrong with this?
And again, we can get bailed
out by a pre-calculus
knowledge of mathematics.
Among other things, notice the
rather interesting property
that if we replace 'x' by 'minus
x' here, we get the
same curve as before.
To generalize this result,
notice that in this particular
case, 'f of x' gives us
the same result as
'f of 'minus x''.
Now this will not happen
in general.
What does that mean if we know
that 'f of x' equals 'f of
'minus x''?
Well, look it.
The relationship between 'x' and
'minus x' is clear, they
are located symmetrically with
respect to the y-axis.
In other words, if this is 'x1',
this will be 'minus x1'.
Now, here's the point.
Let's suppose our curve
happens to be 'y'
equals 'f of x'.
When the input is 'x1', the
output will be 'f of x1'.
When the input is 'minus x1',
the output will be 'f of
'minus x1''.
To say that 'f of 'minus x1''
equals 'f of x1' is the same
as saying that not only are
these two coordinates, 'x1'
and 'minus x1', symmetric with
respect to the y-axis, but the
outputs also are.
In other words, to say that 'f
of x1' equals 'f of 'minus
x1'', says that not only are
these two points the same left
and right displacement for the
y-axis, but they're also the
same height above the x-axis.
In short, this point is the
mirror image of this point.
In terms of a graph, if 'f of x'
equals 'f of 'minus x'' for
all 'x', the graph of 'y' equals
'f of x' is symmetric
with respect to the y-axis.
By the way, that's why we could
rule out this type of
possibility here.
For example, here's
'x1' over here.
Here's 'minus x1'.
And notice that for this choice
of 'x', the points on
the curve are not mirror images
of one another with
respect to the y-axis.
In short, even though we may
not know what this curve is
supposed to look like, the fact
that 'f of x' equals 'f
of 'minus x'' tells us that
whatever the graph is, it
should be symmetric with
respect to the y-axis.
This leads us to a rather
interesting aside.
It's something called 'even
and odd functions' that we
could technically leave out
here, but which I think is a
good place to bring in.
And the fact that there are
many, many places in our
advanced treatment that will
come up later where it's
important to understand what
these things mean, that
perhaps this is a nice place
to bring it into play.
So I call this an aside
and it's about
even and odd functions.
When we have the case that 'f of
x' equals 'f of 'minus x'',
that's the case where in terms
of the graph you have symmetry
with respect to the y-axis such
a function is called an
'even function'.
And I'll come back in a moment
and show you why it's called
even, though it's not
really important.
The counterpart to an even
function as you may guess
almost from the association
of ideas is
called an 'odd function'.
Now an odd function is one for
which 'f of x' is the negative
of 'f of 'minus x''.
See for 'f' to be odd, 'f of x'
has to be the negative of
'f of 'minus x''.
Now what does this
mean pictorially?
Again, 'x1' and 'minus x1' are
symmetrically located with
respect to the y-axis.
This height would be called 'f
of x1' and this height here
would be called 'f
of 'minus x1''.
And to say that these two
heights are equal in magnitude
but opposite in sign
means what?
That these two lengths are equal
but on opposite sides of
the x-axis.
In other words, here's
'f of x1'.
'f of 'minus x1'' is the height
corresponding to this point.
And the fact that these must
be equal in magnitude but
opposite in sign says that one
of the heights must be above
the axis, the other one must
be below the axis.
And if that's the case from some
very elementary geometry,
if 'f' is odd, what it
means with respect to
its graph is this.
If you put a ruler connecting
the origin with any point on
the curve, if you extend that
line that line will meet the
curve again, such that these
distances here will be equal.
This is called symmetry with
respect to the origin.
By the way, an example of
this kind of a curve is
'y' equals 'x cubed'.
You see, if I replace 'x' by
'minus x', this becomes what?
'Minus x cubed'.
And 'minus 'minus x cubed''
is 'x cubed'.
By the way, all I'm saying
now is what?
If I were to take a ruler and
place it here and let this
line go from curve to curve.
all I'm saying is that
this portion
would equal this portion.
And by the way, maybe you can
already guess where the words
even and odd come from.
Notice that when I dealt with
'y' equals 'x squared' I had
an even function.
The exponent was even.
When I dealt with 'y'
equals 'x cubed',
I had an odd function.
The exponent was odd.
And by the way, there
are other examples.
But for the time being, notice
something like say, 'y' equals
'x to the fourth' plus
'x squared' say.
If I replace 'x' by 'minus x',
I get back the same thing.
In other words, here's a case
where if 'y' equals 'f of x',
'f of x' is the same as
'f of 'minus x''.
An example of an odd function
might be 'y' equals 'x cubed'
say, plus 'x'.
See first power over here.
If I replace 'x' by 'minus
x', I have 'minus x
cubed' plus 'minus x'.
That of course, is just 'minus
x cubed' minus 'x'.
And that's minus the quantity
'x cubed + x'.
That when I replace 'x' by
'minus x' all I do is change
the sign here.
In other words, that would be an
example for which 'f of x'
is minus 'f of 'minus x''.
By the way, while we're dealing
with examples like
this, unlike the case with whole
numbers where a whole
number is either even or odd
but not both, it's rather
important to notice that a
function need not be either
even or odd.
And by the way, if you think of
our geometric definition,
that's not too hard to see.
Namely, there's no reason why a
curve drawn at random should
be symmetric either with respect
to the y-axis or with
respect to the origin.
In fact, maybe the quickest way
to see this is to put an
odd power of 'x' in with
an even power of
'x' in the same diagram.
If I now replace 'x' by 'minus
x' you see 'minus x' cubed is
of course, 'minus x cubed'.
But 'minus x' quantity squared
is just 'x squared'.
And now you'll notice that if
I compare these two, I don't
get the same thing nor
do I get the same
thing with a sign change.
You see, in other words, this is
not either equal to this or
to the negative of this.
Obviously you understand that
to be the negative of this,
there would also have to be
a minus sign over here.
Or if we wanted to go into more
detail about this, it is
perhaps exciting to know that
whereas it's not true that
every function is either even or
odd, every function can be
written as the sum of two
functions, one of which is
even, one of which is odd.
Just to give you an idea of what
that means let me just
write down something here.
This will come back to be more
important later on, but for
the time being, just to show you
a connecting thread here
as long as we're talking about
even and odd functions, all I
want to see is the following
identity.
If you write ''f of x' plus
'f of 'minus x'' over 2.
And don't worry about what
motivates this, I just wanted
to show you this to keep
this fairly complete.
Now suppose I add on to that ''f
of x' minus 'f of 'minus
x'' over 2.
You see, notice that the
expression on the right-hand
side is just writing 'f
of x' the hard way.
See, here's half of 'f of x',
here's half of 'f of x'.
The sum is 'f of x'.
And here's half of
'f of 'minus x''.
And I'm subtracting half
of 'f of 'minus x''.
That drops out.
The point is that this is always
an even function and
this is always an
odd function.
And just to review the
definition so that you see
what happens here, all I'm
saying is if I replace 'x' by
'minus x' here, what happens?
If I replace 'x' by 'minus x'
this becomes 'f of 'minus x''.
And if I replace 'x' by 'minus
x' here since minus minus is
plus, this becomes 'f of x'.
Now notice that when you add
two terms, the sum is
independent of the order
in which you add them.
'f of x' plus 'f of 'minus x'',
therefore, is the same as
'f of 'minus x''
plus 'f of x'.
In other words, when I replace
'x' by 'minus x' in this
bracketed function, I do not
change the value of what's in
the brackets.
On the other hand, if I
interchange 'x' with 'minus x'
here, notice that since I'm
subtracting look what happens.
I replace 'x' by 'minus x'.
This gives me an 'f
of 'minus x''.
Now I make the same
replacement here.
Minus minus is positive.
But now notice that if I look at
this expression here, I've
changed the order.
See 'f of x' minus
'f of 'minus x''.
Here, 'f of 'minus x''
minus 'f of x'.
And when you change the order
you change the sign.
In other words then, all I'm
saying is that when we talk
about even and odd functions,
they play a very important
role in calculus and in other
mathematical analysis topics.
That not every function is
either even or odd, but every
function that's defined on the
appropriate domain is the sum
of both an even and
an odd function.
But in terms of curve plotting,
the main point is
not so much these extra remarks
as much as what?
An even function is symmetric
with respect to the y-axis and
an odd function is symmetric
with respect to the origin.
At any rate, if we now go back
to our curve 'y' equals 'x
squared' the fact that 'f of x'
equals 'x squared' is even
means that whatever our graph
looks like, it must be
symmetric with respect
to the y-axis.
Now give or take how I've drawn
this, this should be
symmetric with respect
to the y-axis.
If it doesn't look that way,
imagine that it is that way.
And so the idea is what?
Well, any knowledge of calculus
whatsoever, what I
was able to do here is show that
whatever the graph of 'y'
equals 'x squared' is, it must
never dip below the x-axis.
And whatever the curve looks
like to the right of the
y-axis, it must be the mirror
image of that to the left of
the y-axis.
Again, this is how much one
can do without calculus.
And most of you who are
practicing engineers, I'm sure
not only understand this type
of technique as far as the
pre-calculus is concerned, but
can probably draw curves much
better than I can.
In fact, even if you're not
practicing engineers you can
probably draw curves much
better than I can.
But that part is irrelevant.
What I wanted to show
up to now--
and this is what's important
to stress--
is that to get as far as I've
gotten so far, I did not have
to have any knowledge
of calculus.
The way calculus comes in, as
I say again, is a supplement
to our previous techniques.
For example, let's suppose
we did have the
curve drawn this way.
From this, we certainly aren't
contradicting the fact that
'x' can't be negative.
We're not contradicting
the fact that
'f' is an even function.
But how do we know that this
is the wrong picture?
Well, given that 'y' equals 'x
squared', we can easily verify
that 'dy dx' is '2x.' Knowing
that 'dy dx' is '2x', that
tells us among other things
that 'dy dx' and 'x'
have the same sign.
In other words, 'dy dx' is
positive if 'x' is positive,
'dy dx' is negative if
'x' is negative.
In terms of geometry,
that means what?
That the curve is always rising
for positive values of
'x' and always falling for
negative values of 'x'.
Well, you see with that as
a hint, I say ah-ha.
This can't happen.
Because look what's happening
over here.
Or for that matter, over here.
Here the curve is falling for
positive values of 'x'.
And that contradicts the fact
that the curve must always be
rising when 'x' is positive.
In a similar way, we know that
the curve can't be rising when
'x' is negative, yet get over
here and here too, we've drawn
the curve to be rising.
That again is contradicted
by this diagram.
So you see the knowledge
of the first
derivative does what?
It tells us where the curve is
rising or falling, and that
gives us another way of checking
whether the graph
we've drawn is accurate
or not.
By the way, it's not all
quite that simple.
And notice again, subtlety how
step by step we strengthen our
procedures each time.
For example, now knowing that
the curve must always be
rising when 'x' is positive and
always falling when 'x' is
negative, how about this
possibility for the graph of
'y' equals 'x squared'.
You see this curve is always
fallen for negative values of
'x', it's always rising for
positive values of 'x'.
Let's take a look now at what
the second derivative means.
If 'y' equals 'x squared',
obviously as we saw before,
'dy dx' is '2x' and the second
derivative of 'y' with respect
to 'x' is 2.
And 2 is a constant, which
is always positive.
This says what?
That the second derivative
is always positive.
Now what is the second
derivative?
The second derivative is the
first derivative of the first
derivative.
That means the rate of change
of the rate of change.
Well, the rate of change of the
rate of change is called
acceleration.
So if the rate of change of the
rate of change is positive
that means that the curve must
be accelerating, or the
function is accelerating.
And if it's negative, function
is decelerating.
What does that mean in
terms of a picture?
And the author of the
text uses a very
descriptive phrase here.
He talks about 'holding water'
and 'spilling water'.
Notice, for example, here the
curve would tend to collect
water, whereas here if water
were poured on it, the curve
would tend to spill water.
Holding water represents
acceleration.
You see that not only is the
curve rising here, but it's
rising at a faster
and faster rate.
Again, more primitively,
in terms of
slopes, notice that what?
Not only is the slope positive,
but as you move
along this portion of the curve,
the slope increases as
you move along.
And what typifies
this portion?
That even though the slope is
always positive, it decreases
as you move along the curve.
In other words, 'holding water'
corresponds to the
second derivative being
positive, 'spilling water'
corresponds to the second
derivative being negative.
Returning then to our original
problem, the fact that this
thing here is greater than 0
for all 'x' says that this
curve could never spill water.
And that rules out this
portion in here.
In other words, now
we put everything
together, we know what?
The curve can never go
below the x-axis.
It's symmetric with respect
to the y-axis.
It's always rising when
'x' is positive and
always holding water.
Now you see this is what I call
curve sketching versus
curve plotting.
With the information that I
have from calculus, I know
what's going on for each
point, not just for the
isolated points that I happened
to have plotted in
the data for.
See, the calculus fills
in the missing
data very, very nicely.
Now you see this does not mean
I'm going to replace this by--
my previous analysis
by calculus.
It means I'm going to add
calculus as one of my bags of
tools here.
Notice again that there is a
very nice relationship between
pictures and analysis.
And I'm not going to
belabor that point.
All I'm saying is that if
you add to our previous
identifications--
what identifications?
Like increase means rising.
I mean this, if a derivative
is positive,
the curve is rising.
If a derivative is negative,
the curve is falling.
If the second derivative
is positive, the
curve is holding water.
If the second derivative is
negative, the curve is
spilling water.
And again, we have ample
exercises and portions of this
in the reading material
to illustrate the
computational aspects.
But again, all I want you to
get from this lecture is
what's happening here
conceptually.
Let's look at this, a few
more applications.
We're going to find in
subsequent lectures as well as
other portions of the course,
we're going to be interested,
for example, in things called
stationary points.
A 'stationary point' is a point
at which the curve is
neither rising nor falling.
In other words, if the curve
happens to be smooth, it's
characterized by the fact that
'dy dx' is 0 it such a point.
In terms of the language of
functions to say that the
curve is smooth means that the
function is differentiable and
what we're saying is to be
stationary at 'x' equals 'x1',
it must be that 'f prime
of x1' equals 0.
And the importance of stationary
points can be seen
in terms of a physical
interpretation.
We haven't used our freely
falling body for quite a
while, let's go back
to such an example.
Suppose a particle is projected
vertically upward in
the absence of air resistance,
et cetera, with an initial
speed of 160 feet per second.
It can then be shown that the
height 's' to which the ball
rises in feet at time
't' is given by
'160t - 16't squared''.
A very natural question to ask
is, when will the ball be at
its maximum height?
And I'm sure you can see in
terms of this physical
example, the ball will be at
its maximum height when the
velocity is 0.
In other words, since this is
a smooth type of motion, if
the velocity is not 0, the
ball is still rising.
If the velocity is positive,
the ball is still rising.
If the velocity is negative, the
ball is already falling.
Consequently, if the speed is
smooth, which it is in this
case, the only way it can go
from rising to falling is to
first level off and the
velocity must be 0.
But you see, what
is the velocity?
The velocity is the derivative
of the displacement.
In other words, without solving
this problem, which is
not important here, to find the
time at which you have the
maximum height, you
simply do what?
Set the derivative equal to 0.
In other words, stationary
points tell us where we have
high and low points
for functions.
And knowing where we have high
and low points is a very
important portion in
curve plotting.
We'll talk about this in a
future lecture very shortly in
more detail.
But coming back here to what we
were talking about before,
what we're saying in terms of
curve plotting is that where
the derivative is 0 gives us a
good candidate to have either
a low point on the curve
or to have a high
point on the curve.
However, we should not read
more into this than what's
already there.
Namely, it's possible
that you have what?
A situation like this, in which
the derivative is 0
here, but the curve is
rising every place.
And secondly, there is the
possibility that if the
derivative doesn't exist,
for example, if
there's a sharp corner.
Where you have a sharp corner
notice that-- see this is a
straight line, this is
a straight line.
In this special case, the
derivative is the slope of
this straight line.
Derivative here is the slope
of this straight line.
Therefore, the derivative is
positive on this line,
negative on this line.
Yet the point is what?
At their junction, there's
a discontinuity.
The function is continuous,
but the derivative isn't.
And at that particular point
notice that you have a high
point even though the derivative
doesn't exist at
that particular point.
All we're saying is what?
That for a smooth curve if there
is to be a high point or
a low point, a maximum or a
minimum, and we'll talk about
this as I say, in a future
lecture, it must be that at
particular point the
derivative is 0.
On the other hand, conversely,
if the derivative is 0, you
may not have a high
or low point.
It may be what we call a saddle
point, the curve just
levels off after rising
and then rises again.
And secondly, if the function
isn't differentiable, or the
curve isn't smooth at that
particular point, you can have
a high or a low point regardless
of what the
knowledge about the
derivative is.
Just a little buckshot here to
give you an idea of how we're
going to use this material.
A very related topic that's also
quite important here is
something called points
of inflection.
Points of inflection are, in a
way, to the second derivative
what stationary points are
to the first derivative.
In many cases, we are interested
in knowing, where
does the curve change
its concavity?
Where does it go, in other
words, from holding water to
spelling water?
And by the way, again, in
terms of a geometrical
interpretation, there's a very
what I call exciting answer to
this question.
It almost results in what looks
like an optical illusion.
You see, if a curve is holding
water, the tangent line lies
below the curve.
If the curve is spilling water,
the tangent line to the
curve at a point lies
above the curve.
Consequently, at a 'point of
inflection', meaning where the
curve changes concavity, the
tangent line on one side must
be above the curve, on the other
side below the curve.
And all I'm saying over here is
that you recognize a point
of inflection by what?
It's the situation in which
the tangent line
to the curve appears--
in fact, it actually does
in the manner of
speaking, cross the curve.
I think we talked about
this in the previous
lecture, I'm not sure.
But we talked about the idea
that a tangent line
can cross the curve.
And where can it cross the curve
and still be a tangent
line at that point?
At a point of inflection.
By the way, if this is a
smooth type of thing in
general, what we're saying is
that for a point of inflection
to occur, the second derivative
must be 0.
You see because that
means what?
The curve is neither--
it's going from holding to
spilling, so it goes through a
transition where it's
doing neither.
In the same as with first
derivatives, the mere fact
that the second derivative
is 0 does not allow us to
conclude that we have a
point of inflection.
In fact, let me close with this
particular illustration.
Let's take the curve 'y' equals
'x to the fourth'.
The first derivative
is '4 x cubed'.
The second derivative
is '12 x squared'.
The curve is symmetric
with respect to
the y-axis, et cetera.
Using all of the given data you
know the second derivative
is always positive,
what have you.
We can sketch this curve.
And again, in fact the
uninitiated say this curve
looks like a parabola.
What do you mean it looks
like a parabola?
Well, he says, the parabola does
something like this too.
Well, what do we mean by
something like this?
I want to mention a
few points here.
One is, of course, that
actually, the parabola 'y'
equals 'x squared'.
These are going to crisscross
very shortly here.
It doesn't make any
difference.
The parabola 'y' equals 'x
squared' has the same general
shape but with a few different
properties, which we'll
mention in a little while.
But the point that I wanted to
mention here first of all is
simply this.
At the value 'x' equals 0,
'y double prime' is 0.
So you notice that the second
derivative is 0 over here.
Yet even though the second
derivative is 0, notice that
the curve does not
change concavity.
The curve here is always
holding water.
The concluding remark that I
wanted to make is, what is the
relationship between 'y' equals
'x squared' and 'y'
equals 'x to the fourth'?
Or how about 'y' equals
'x to the sixth'?
Or 'y' equals 'x to the 12th'?
Notice that any curve in
that family will look
something like this.
Only what?
As the exponent goes up, the
curve becomes broader in the
neighborhood of 0.
And then once 'x' passes 1, the
curve rises more sharply.
See what we're saying is, if the
magnitude of 'x' is less
than 1, the higher a power
you raise it to,
the smaller 'y' is.
On the other hand, if the
absolute value of 'x' is
greater than 1, the higher a
power you raise it to, the
bigger the output becomes.
But the idea is this.
Notice that the exponent--
in other words, how many
derivatives are 0, gives you a
way of getting into a problem
that will become very, very
crucial as this course
continues.
And it's the idea of, can one
curve be more tangent to a
line than another curve?
You see, all of these curves are
tangent to the line what?
The x-axis, 'y' equals
0 at 'x' equals 0.
How do we distinguish between
these curves?
Well, it seems that some of
these curves fit the x-axis
better than others in a
neighborhood of the
point 'x' equals 0.
See the point that I want to
bring out as to 'y' curve
plotting tells us things that we
don't learn in the ordinary
physics class is this.
If you study calculus the way
it comes up in most physics
courses, we essentially don't go
past the second derivative.
Why?
Because in many cases, we're
studying distance.
And the derivative of distance
is velocity.
The second derivative of
distance, namely the
derivative of velocity
is acceleration.
And we don't usually talk
physically beyond
acceleration.
But notice that in terms of
curve plotting the third,
fourth, fifth, sixth, seventh,
tenth derivatives all have a
meaning that gives you
more information
than what came before.
Don't be deceived by the fact
that in other applications
that you never go past the
second derivative means that
there is no value to knowing how
higher order derivatives
are related to plotting
curves.
At any rate, I think this is
enough of an introduction to
the topic of curve plotting
and curve sketching.
We'll pursue these topics
further in our next lectures.
So until next time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.